hazel is broken finally happened
no thanks to
tim
hazel is
hazel's broken so a couple of weeks ago
i made a video called just a chill
devlog and to my surprise a lot of you
seemed to like it it was just a very
very chill video i just hit record and
that's something that honestly i have
vowed to do more of um so hopefully this
is kind of a continuation of that format
i'm just going to put in more of an
effort to document the kind of work we
do here at like studio channel so in
that chill devlog video i mentioned that
hazel is kind of a little bit broken
right now the quality of like the main
release kind of branch is not very good
and i wanted to make an effort to try
and improve that quality and make it a
little bit better so rather than just
doing it magically behind the scenes i'm
going to show you all of the work that
goes into doing something like that like
what do i mean by how am i going to
improve the quality what are the
processes that we're going to implement
as part of our development cycle and
like literally what is going to happen
so that's what we're here for today
we're going to fix hazel together um i'm
going to document the process of doing
this i'm probably not going to do this
in like one sitting i'm just going to
film you know throughout the week and
hopefully it's what this will be like
more of a devlog kind of devlog where
i kind of check in maybe every day and
show you kind of what's changed as well
as probably i'll try and include some of
the work obviously can't include all of
it because it's going to be just too
much but i'm going to try to include
some of the work here and there so you
see some real work not just you know
updates of me being like yeah so i've
done this and you know like whatever i
don't know devlogs are weird so over
here in our master branch we've kind of
got like a master branch and then a dev
branch a dev branch is where all the
other feature branches get merged into
and then master kind of acts as like a
release branch and it's a default it's a
default branch of the repository i'm
really contemplating kind of renaming
maybe master to release because that
would make more sense but anyway the
last commit there was 15th of june which
is like almost a month ago today's the
11th of july so and the reason for that
is because in that
previous chill devlog i mentioned that i
locked master like no one can push to
master except for me uh and i obviously
haven't pushed anything to mass and the
idea is this our release branch is kind
of locked in uh you know no more
features no more weird code going in
there it's all kind of tightly
controlled so that we can make sure that
master kind of represents like a fully
qa tested final product if that makes
sense you know of a given
version of hazel and so we have another
branch called dev which as i mentioned
is where all of the other
people that work on the team they merge
their feature branches into dev and if
there are like small fixes or small
little features you can just add them
directly into dev that's fine which is
how master was treated before which as
you can imagine is a bit of a problem
since master was that first branch that
everyone sees and so if someone just
pushes some code that maybe isn't fully
tested it could break the just
everyone's version of hazel basically as
soon as they pull so i want to i want to
have that master be a little bit more
control so because master
is quite old at this point in times like
a month old and also like dev
i mean dev is like the version i've more
or less been using so like in the
previous version of my ray tracing
series which i'll leave up there i
actually used hazel to visualize like
rey's being shot out from the camera to
explain how like ray casting and ray
tracing works and that was that was off
of depth right so it is stable the idea
is it should be fairly stable but it's
just not as fully tested because
obviously you know in a game engine
there's a lot of features and testing
every single one of those features every
time is a little bit of a pain and so
whilst dev is
is more or less stable it's still not
like we can't guarantee that everything
works that's what master is for um so
what i want to do as like step one here
is basically just merge
dev into master but i don't really like
i'm so normally the way we would do this
is a little bit more
stable than that like we don't want to
merge dev into master because if we do
that then whilst i whilst qa kind of
goes in and tries to make sure
everything is good and qa is just us you
know we don't really have a dedicated qa
team or anything like that but anyway
once the qa pass kind of happens while
it's going on obviously you've just
pushed a commit to master
that is untested and so therefore master
is now unstable so instead of doing that
you probably want to make another branch
called like master release or master
temp or whatever you want to call it
maybe devmaster i i don't know i don't
want to get too confusing with names
here but basically the idea is you make
another branch which kind of will
will be your like qa testing branch and
as that gets tested and as potential
fixes get pushed into that branch
you know you keep master
at its previous release so that it's all
still stable and then once that's done
you just basically replace the master
branch with that branch so you can just
like fast forward or just merge whatever
now the reason why you can't simply have
have qa test dev is because obviously
other people on the team are going to
continue committing to dev
right if you have a team and you're not
just a solo developer then there's going
to be other people merging their feature
branches in other people adding little
features to dev you know dev is like the
main kind of working branch and so we
don't we can't just get qa to test that
because i mean we could get qa to test a
particular commit in the dev branch but
that complicates the fix process because
we need to apply fixes to just that
commit because obviously any any more
kind of new commits that have come in
they're not tested anymore and so it's
just easier to just make a make a branch
so i'll probably make a branch called
release for now um and that's going to
act as like our kind of
the branch that we send to qa
they will test that fixes will be
implemented into release release will be
branched off of dev so that way any
fixes that go into release they'll
simply be pulled back into dev as well
so dev will get them and then master
will essentially be replaced by the
final kind of everything's fixed and
tested version of the release branch and
then you could just delete release i
mean i might call it something like
release pending
or something uh maybe that would make
more sense because the idea is obviously
like it does get published into that
master branch which i might rename to
release anyway lots of names lots of
lots of release lots of mars lots of dev
going on
not enough work so let's get let's get
into it so tim's been working on on a
scene actually in hazel now what branch
are you off
uh this is dev this is dev okay cool so
this is the dev branch
right it's pretty uh
stable
um
can you play that again
and show that duck that's cute
so yeah we've we've been doing some
animation work um and there'll probably
be a devlog
specifically about that a little bit
later so tim has been putting together
this scene that highlights
animation um
but the trees are moving and
everything's kind of
yeah kind of cool
um but yeah so
but in general tim what would you say
has been your experience working with
hazel in terms of like stability and
stuff um
honest answer yeah
it's been a bit of a give-and-take
to say the least like yeah sometimes
there's been stuff that has been working
for months and then just all of a sudden
just stops working yeah
which usually those features get back up
and running within a day or so but
yeah like it's
sometimes like you're very used to
something working and then you know that
workflow and then you you kind of have
to invent a new workflow because all of
a sudden that doesn't work that's what
tim does instead of telling the rest of
the team hey this is broken tim like
invents new workflow no no i tell the
team like hey this doesn't work anymore
and then i'm like well can i actually
work on what i was working without
waiting for this feature to get fixed
yeah yeah by sweden or stockholm
tweeted by stockholm yeah we don't call
peter peter anymore we just call him
sweden sweden the sweden branch of hazel
development
i guess the other thing is that
like as hazel grows obviously people
might not even be aware of all of the
features there and so tim's primary job
is to use hazel
and he's he should be fairly aware of
all of the features and obviously he
uses hazel to a much greater extent than
any of the other developers on the team
and so someone can come along and commit
something and
you know their stuff might work and
their understanding of hazel might work
but tim might be using a feature that
they're not even aware of
and that's where the breakage can happen
as well yeah but i also feel like a lot
of this stuff is like on repositories
that people have access to on the team
so like i feel like a lot of the time
that they just don't open up like space
invaders for example yes yeah and that's
why like i open it up because i might
need something or need to double check
something like and then it's like hey
this doesn't actually work all these
crashes on playable or something yeah
that's a good point i might ask how
how many people on the team actually
test
hazel with the games that we've made
yeah because that's
obviously important
well and it's also just a good use case
of like a bunch of different systems
come into play in a finished product so
i think it's just a good idea to run
those at least yeah
i agree we've got this dev master
directory which is the master branch
and then we have dev dev i used to
prefix uh all the kind of branches of
hazel with dev just in my local
directories
because we used to have hazel dev right
there was hazel which was which is now
hazel 2d and then
real big boy hazel which is which used
to be called hazel def that's why it's a
bit confusing now should rename that but
anyway devmaster is master you can see
it's the master branch um and yeah as i
was saying it's uh 15th of june right so
15th of
june uh is quite a while ago and then we
have 11th of july actually which is
today and that is the dev branch and you
can see there's been quite a lot of work
if we just scroll down through this i'm
regretting my facecam
placement but this should be visible so
if we scroll down from 11th of july you
can get an idea as to how much work
uh you know goes into hazel so 15th of
june is all the way back here this is
basically all the stuff
that all the way down to here is what
needs to be merged into master and if we
clear like the filter of branches
because that that was just the dev
branch right um you can see people have
other branches as well we need to take
all this new stuff and merge it into
master or an intermediate branch before
it actually hits master the problem with
that and one of the complications to
consider is like what is the divergence
between master and dev
and the answer is there should be none
if everything is done correctly there
should be none and i believe there is
none because if we take a look at this
so master is red it can be a little bit
difficult to read these kinds of maybe
make it bigger
it can be a little bit difficult to read
these kinds of um
uh you know trees and all these diagrams
that you get when using git so i'll
hopefully kind of explain that a little
bit here and maybe that will help you
out but basically you can see there's a
dot here
and this dot is kind of on this red path
and red is kind of
master now
this red is also a branch but it's the
sound graph branch so i don't know
sometimes it picks with weird colors i
don't entirely understand
why that's the case
um
but basically these colors represent
branches so you can see if i scroll up
all the way up to the top we have uh
this dev branch for example we have this
like ragdolls branch which is um
yellow right this one's orange and then
the master was red so if we go down and
we find a master we can see that you
know this commit here because this is
shown kind of
in uh like a linear fashion it's shown
in order of like the timestamp it's
sorted by time
and so that's why you have to be like
okay well what branches for example this
commit on and you can see it's on the
master branch because there's a little
dot here on this red thing so this
commit only applies to master so that's
why i like to usually filter by active
branch in fork because otherwise as you
can imagine it's very difficult to see
what actually like makes it into what
branch and especially when people
diverge and stuff like that the reason
why this is even shown here though is
because this actually eventually this
commit
gets merged as you can see into this
orange branch so orange is dev
and you can see this kind of red line
here it goes into here and this is the
merge branch master
into scripting supposedly but really
it's also going into
dev so this was kind of the merge uh
master into scripting as it was back
then because you can also see this is a
scripting branch but it's because like
scripting was then merged kind of into
dev dev was renamed there's been a bunch
of stuff that's happened and so
dev is kind of now the scripting branch
so yeah this stuff can be very
complicated my point here is that master
you can see has been merged into what is
now the dev branch that's why like all
of these commits are also relevant to
dev
but otherwise if we take a look at the
rest of master and you can see that kind
of terminates here so here in this one
this is the one with master actually
checked out you can see it only if i
clear the filter it's kind of red here
now uh and it's it's the active kind of
commit and that's all that's happened
and if i kind of filter back to branch
you can see this now shows you what the
repository is like based on this branch
but anyway so back here the reason why
this is important and we want to look at
this stuff is because we need to have an
understanding of everything that's gone
into
this branch and if it differs from dev
so the fact that this has been merged
into dev is good that's kind of the
correct procedure and then now what i'm
hoping for is no more commits into
master and we know that there are no
more commits because if i fetch uh you
can see we have this little gitlab logo
which tells us what is on the origin
so we can talk about remotes as well
there's going to be a get tutorial but
uh remotes basically are
the remote copies of the repositories so
it's basically like servers that are
hosting your repository you can have
multiple obviously like you might push
your repository to github and gitlab if
you wanted to you could partially push
certain branches to certain repositories
you can keep other branches private and
not push them into like a public
repository
but if we just edit this for example you
can see that this origin the origin is
just a name i don't know why it's it's
called origin i guess because it's kind
of like the host
but uh
you can see that it's pointing towards
um the main kind of hazeldub repository
which is the one that's accessible by
patrons so anyway because i've just
fetched to make sure that i actually
have everything downloaded from the
server all the information
and the fact that we have this origin
master here it tells me that the version
on the server is this kind of
086190c checkout
and then also locally i'm also like my
master branch is on this as well so i
don't have any local commits or anything
like that so this is the final kind of
master
uh
version and that's really important
because again it got merged into dev the
reason why this is important is because
it tells me that there haven't been any
additional fixes that might have gone
into master this could have happened if
there were like some emergency things
that are like oh no this like crashes or
whatever let's quickly patch that up and
maybe those fixes haven't been pulled
back into dev and that's important
because i'm about to go through a
different kind of release workflow here
so as i mentioned earlier this is kind
of the stage where i want to be able to
test everything that we have in dev i've
now made sure that we don't have
anything extra in master everything that
is in master is also in dev now now
that's important to make sure because we
don't want to lose work and also we want
to make sure that everything is tested
so now the thing to avoid is other
people pushing to death so i've decided
that this kind of commit over here is
the one that we're essentially going to
publish and so this is going to go into
our release thing so there's a few ways
we could deal with this uh i think what
i'm going to do is probably just like
create a new branch out of this and i'm
going to call this release pending as i
mentioned earlier because i think a
master will be eventually called release
so i can create and check out make sure
it's on this and then if i want to i can
push just to create this kind of release
pending tracking reference on the actual
origin like server so that this is now
like an official branch that people can
access so now release pending is a real
branch you can see that it is in fact
like in the gitlab and that's obviously
important because we want everyone to be
able to access this and really all it is
at the moment is just like a little
pointer into this specific commit on dev
but that obviously means that now the
rest of the team can continue committing
to dev merging their features in fixing
stuff
adding little features doing whatever
they would do on the dev branch and
meanwhile qa can kind of focus on
release pending so as a little side note
um you may have noticed all of this
like
clutter that's just chilling
like behind me in the videos for like
the last month
and i know some people were were being
like what's going on with with this like
why is this here and it's a funny story
that i thought i should
tell so basically
i had the great idea
of setting up a nas in the office
um because a nasa is like a basically
it's a hard drive that hooks that's
hooked up to like the network or a
series of hard drives so we wanted some
storage that was
network attached
uh the reason being that obviously tim
and i work here he wants to share assets
with me we've been kind of just uh
dropping it onto each other's computers
just using like the normal windows 10
like you know network sharing
whatever system which is not bad but
then we also kind of wanted peter to be
able to access it from sweden and so it
made sense to kind of set up a little
server that would basically be like a
nas that we could just access from
anywhere and i was going to buy an ass
but then linus tech tips is like no
don't buy a nuts you can build your own
for for less
and
that was a a good suggestion um i mean
honestly it was a good suggestion uh
you can see how it worked out though but
anyway it was a good suggestion if i
bought an ass we'd probably have a nap
so let's be honest
be honest
anyway it was a good suggestion uh
because like the for the price way
cheaper
you know and better i guess to build
your own because you could just select
much higher quality components
um you know you can have way more ram
you can upgrade it as you see fit and it
comes out to being like almost the same
price as like a higher end kind of nas
and so not like a an enterprise nas but
like a higher end like normal kind of
small scale mass and so
uh the problem though here
is
uh it worked for like a week and
everything was great yeah i was just
like putting files on
i only bought like a single eight
terabyte drive for now i was gonna
upgrade it maybe run it in like raid
zero or five or whatever
um
but then it stopped working it just
didn't like boot up
and
uh it was a bit weird but luckily the
cpu i had selected
was
ryzen 5 5600 g
that's going to be important later um so
this has a this has a graphics processor
like it's got integrated graphics built
into it and the reason why i wanted that
is because obviously like you know we're
not putting a gpu into this
um but i wanted to be able to like you
know hook up a monitor to the system to
like set up truenas which is what we
ended up using as the operating system
and just you know debug it and do
whatever right anyway long story short
we connected the display like nothing
works
it doesn't post it seems it doesn't get
any video output so like huh maybe
something's broken i thought it was the
motherboard um
i don't know why i just
thought maybe it's the motherboard you
know we tried obviously removing ram and
doing all this stuff then we put the cpu
into tim's computer
uh
i just took tim's computer apart and i
was like okay let's just chuck in the
the 5600 g
you know into there
to see if we get anything and meanwhile
we
got the i don't know what tim what cpu
do you have all right so tim actually
has a 5600 x so it's the same as this
but the g is the graphics version so
this is this one has an integrated
graphics chips chip that one does not
so we chucked tim's 5600x into this
motherboard and then also took it out of
the case so that we could connect like a
gpu to it to get like some kind of video
output and yeah it worked uh meanwhile
this guy the the 5600g inside tim's
computer does not post
with the gpu without the gpu i mean it's
got integrated so it should work but
yeah this does not work
what are the answers cpu died
same symptoms
but it could be just the graphical side
of the cpu yeah
yeah okay
uh
gp is going back in then
will it be able to pick a gpu on the
flower though well what do you mean the
video output is
plugged directly into this yeah sure
okay nothing damn young look at that you
were wrong
what do you mean you went with
motherboard yeah but so did you
that's true so that motherboard's fine
let's try let's chuck my cpu into this
motherboard all right now the other fury
on because it did not follow all the
necessary checks
you could have fried the cpu you just
sent because you didn't have a cooler
attached
yeah likely
very we're gonna start your cpu without
a cooler and see what oh young please
don't you fried the cpu young
wait it's there okay it's that way
because it's like what are you doing
you're cooking me a lot
sure now i want to see the temp
but he's gonna run this for a while
80 degrees yes yes
look 83 yeah it heats up like this
it's cool that is quick a minute and
it's cooking not 84 i can't believe you
said 10 minutes without it no well 84
105 is like the max recommended
temperature
yeah but you're also not doing anything
well yeah
he's not doing well i'm not saying let's
like run the house without a call i'm
just saying oop 85 or i'm killing it
that was like genuinely that was that
was
a few minutes yeah that was less than 60
seconds that was quick here we go he has
a 90 degree cpu be careful it's hard
genuinely as we found out yeah see this
one wasn't when i unplugged it for the
record it was warm
yeah but not as hot as that yeah but
also
it never actually ran i guess well
exactly because it's a pile of garbage
holy
smokes actually so far
i don't know the top's found out
the red that young cpu without a cool
abusing cpus
yep
wax
all right
guess it's not the motherboard cyan
what's what's going on what is actually
first of all the cpu fan is in fact
working and your cpu is just 33 degrees
well anyway turns out that
the amd
5600g cpu does not work
and
it looks like the bios supports it oh we
can verify the bios f15 yeah that's why
i flashed it to yesterday actually
yeah f15
and it's there which is supported
which does support the 5600 g and yet
the cpu is broken
don't know why it worked fine for like a
week or two and then suddenly
boom when you decided to copy one
terabyte of data it was like hold up
body how did you're an eight core cpu or
six cores if you had to late at a
terabyte of data
that's just too much and decompress it
on the fly
so conclusion to this very long story
is this cpu does not work anymore but it
worked for like a week
so i have been trying to contact amd to
get like this fixed
uh and
that's a story in and of itself because
what happened was
uh i contacted them
and then like two days later got sick
with covert so i had to stay at home
and meanwhile amd were like oh yeah hey
we're happy to help just send like
absolutely like a photo from every angle
of the cpu
i want it i want it installed in the
motherboard i want it installed not in
the motherboard i want basically they
just wanted like does it have scratches
is it and i'm like no guys like it just
doesn't post anymore and it's been
sitting there it's clearly like brand
new it's like a week old but anyway
whatever so i didn't send any of those
photos because i was at home
and uh they only gave like i think a
week or ten days or something for um
you know until they auto closed the
ticket so that that support ticket got
got closed and we're stuck here again so
i'm gonna have to open another one
and provide them with like some kind of
3d photo scan of this cpu so they can
see that it's not damaged and then maybe
we'll get a replacement or something and
i'll have to mail this to them i guess
and then we'll have a nas so
that is the road to nass story so most
people
thought that would be a bad idea
may 12. see that's how that's how long
ago this whole
debacle was yeah
yeah
hashtag narnasslive